la reine des neiges est plus qu'un film
avec tous ses produits dérivés
c'est aussi une planche à imprimer de
l'argent oui j'aime phocéenne et
gémissent rr parler de noël
je vais m'acheter m la forteresse de
frozen puis la voiture frozen plusieurs
états les princesses afin d'annoncer sa
ville les magasins de jouets déroule le
tapis rouge pour la reine du box office
au canada il existe plus de 150 produits
différents associés au film reine des
neiges numéro 2 la savate ait vraiment
vraiment b comme conduit histoire de
jouets
harry potter tous ces films s'invite sur
les tablettes depuis longtemps
hollywood a flairé la bonne affaire on
estime ce marché-là à 280 milliards de
dollars
juste pour vous donner une idée on dit
que les disney on accapare 50 4
milliards de dollars à lui seul l'arrêt
de dix des neiges en 2013-2014 a généré
environ 1 point 3 milliards de dollars
au niveau des entrées pour vous allez
voir le film et on estime que minimum
ils ont au moins vendu pour 1.3 milliard
de dollars en produits
le premier volet de la guerre des
étoiles sorti en 1977 a été un réveil
pour les studios de films qui ont
constaté que la force est avec les
produits dérivés
depuis ses débuts la franchise a récolté
20 milliards de dollars en produits de
toutes sortes car sur chaque objet vendu
dans les magasins
le studio reçoit un pourcentage ces
pourcentages l'oeil c'est entre 3 et 10%
la moyenne est environ 2 8 % mais je
dirais que pour les produits storeway
saviez-vous c'était combien le
pourcentage 20% en tête des ventes des
objets les plus prisées on retrouve les
vêtements suivi par les jeux et les
jouets et par les accessoires mais y'a
même des bananes avec des autocollants
bas rhin des neiges ici au québec passe
partout et toujours été un gros vendeur
de produits dérivés en fait eu aucun
hasard la première émission été lancé le
25 février
on a fait une première phase pour leur
retour à l'école et la balle approche
des fêtes on sort la deuxième vague
donc oui oui tout et c'était vraiment
pensé pour semer les gens ont trouvé
qu'on sortait pas si vite
la sortie du film la reine des neiges
quelques semaines avant noël les par
hasard et le père noël devrait s'y faire
ici mais bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal